welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode 2 which explores what
would happen if t'challa became
star-lord spared us all from thanos and
left us with the collector cosplaying as
hella
those antlers don't belong to you you
don't deserve it set in my favorite
corner of the mcu the cosmic toy box of
the guardians of the galaxy this episode
is filled with easter eggs and subtle
details so let's break this down frame
by frame for everything you missed and
big announcement here we have a new
latest obsession shirt cosmic witness
that you can get at our merch store new
rockstarsmerch.com this shirt is awesome
but like all of our latest obsessions
limited supply and when you get this one
you'll get the added option to write in
a custom shout out that will appear at
the bottom of our inside marvel after
shows so again you can support new
rockstars directly by getting this shirt
at new rockstarsmerch.com we open on
morag coordinates m31b j04 37.99 plus
4129 236 the same as those in james
gunn's 2014 film coordinates that gunn
has hinted point toward his infamous
long-lost hidden easter egg that he
confirmed we at new rockstars got a big
piece of the watcher ponders is your
destiny determined by your nature or by
the nature of your world get in at the
deeper theme of nature vs nurture in
this episode both guardians films
explore the idea of family and whether
peter quill is forever cursed by his
biological lineage or capable of
redefining himself with a family of his
own choosing this episode ends up making
a compelling case for nurture with
formerly scarred characters like yondu
thanos nebula and drax all positively
benefiting from the experience of the
fresh altruism of t'challa in their
lives and t'challa's formerly royal
attitude of non-interference now
reshaped by his life as an explorer with
all of them and this episode ends with a
dark cautionary tale favoring nurture
with the fear of what would have
happened had peter quill not been
nurtured by his chosen family this
opening scene has a few contrasts
between t'challa's approach and quills
t'challa doesn't have an awesome mixed
playlist to dance to and quill put the
gravity trap on the floor whereas
t'challa holds it in his hand and later
repurposes it as a weapon and of course
there's korath's reaction i'm just a
junker man i was just just checking
stuff out hey you know what there's
another name you might know me by
star-lord who star-lord man legendary
outlaw versus i'm just an ordinary
junker but there is one name you may
know me by starlord i'm a huge fan of
your work now chadwick boseman voiced
tachala here one of four episodes this
season that he recorded voices for
before he passed away a year ago this
month jaimon hansu returns his core app
and he's having a lot of goofy fun in
the role he says should we be bowing i
feel like we should be bowing i mean
unless we should be kneeling neither is
necessary please similar to bruce
banner's reaction to meeting t'challa in
infinity war should we bow
yeah he's the king
what are you doing
we we don't do that here michael rooker
returns to voice yondu whose animated
form has fewer random straps and his
jacket is a brighter ravager red than
the darker tone of his live-action
wardrobe showing off how he's not as too
cool as he was before less of an
overlord of his crew and more one of the
guys t'challa says if we still made like
the old days you'd only have half of
your teeth yeah in the film yondu had a
mouth full of golden teeth but here you
can see all of his teeth are still
mostly in place t'challa continues
besides wouldn't you rather use it to
jumpstart the colorian's dying star save
their system from extinction colonians
that's a deep cut to the rom comics of
the 80s where colonians were a race of
cat-like beings t'challa wants to save
him because he comes from a
panther-oriented culture and he probably
has an affinity for all things feline
now instead of the milano t'challa named
his ship the mandela my favorite detail
from this episode when t'challa was
abducted in the year 1988 nelson mandela
was still a political prisoner mandela's
south african dialect of hosie was what
the spoken language of wakandan was
based on for the film and mandela's
voice recently came out in the mcu
echoing through the cosmos in the loki
finale we have fought for the right to
experience peace now 20 years earlier in
wakanda young t'challa meets with his
father tachaka with john connie
returning to voice the role in the
wakandan throne room numerous
traditional tribal garb over his black
panther suit both of them are dressed as
they were in a very brief flashback in
black panther interesting detail here as
tachaka first walks up there are two
thrones side by side perhaps for t'chaka
and queen ramonda or for father and son
but later in the wide angle it's back to
just the one throne maybe an oversight
or a sign of t'challa's abdication by
leaving her behind the watcher's
voiceover says what you call destiny is
just an equation
a product of variables yeah interesting
choice of words when you consider the
recent what if promo displayed uwatu's
pitch using the interface of the tva
follow me
enter the multiverse of infinite
possibilities
[Music]
where the stories you thought you knew
are nothing like you remember
no treasure is worth as much as the good
that can be done with it and describing
the multiverse as a math equation
mirrors the explanation of he who
remains creator of the tva in that loki
finale he had a series of non-linear
integration equations on his chalkboard
yeah just know these two are speaking a
very similar language and i will remind
you that in our season preview i
predicted a post-credit scene in which
he remains host the watcher in his
citadel chamber moments before loki and
sylvia arrived the wakandan border wall
has as it does in the films a hexagonal
grid structure which matches the unt and
navigation grid of the universe seen in
the guardians films captain marvel and
endgame later this episode we will learn
that the wakandans were actually
experienced in space travel meaning some
of their tech might have been
extraterrestrial influence craiglin is
voiced by sean gunnigan and taser vase a
mutineer in volume two voiced again by
chris sullivan explain i don't know all
humans look alike to me the cosmic
readings where he was took nearly broke
our dial if there was anything not from
that planet on that planet it's there
referring to the meteorite and the
prologue of black panther that's now the
minds of mount bashanga but then back in
the present 20 years later the crew
hangs out on contrexia that's a
snow-covered planet that we saw in
guardians volume 2 but whereas those
ravagers hung out in the scummy street
level these guys kick it in the classy
nightclub still throughout the
background you can see the yellow sex
spots hanging about they relive their
war stories what about the central bank
heist of don x4 never hurts to hurt a
scroll right
yeah tarnax 4 is the skrull home world
first mentioned in the mcu it might in
the live action things be under cree
occupation since the squirrels were
refugees in captain marvel we might
visit this place in the marvel film
korath says oh how about when you own
the anchorage resistance yeah in the
marvel comics ankara is the homeworld of
the slig it's from a 1979 fantastic four
comic and then this reveal how exactly
did you stop thanos the mad titan from
decimating half of the universe oh no
i'm a big enough man to admit when i'm
wrong josh brolin returns as thanos
having moved on from being a malthusian
eco-terrorist thanks to t'challa shown
in the light now t'challa having grown
up in a bubble untarnished by
imperialist conflict instead in a
peaceful state of tribes who settle
their differences at warrior falls and
share their resources with each other
might have been that x factor to break
through to thanos sociopathy and yeah 20
years after 1988 would be 2008 right as
tony stark started to become iron man
and four years before thanos would have
sent loki to attack earth so this thanos
hasn't even gotten close to his conquest
of earth in his warpath in the infinity
saga the bartender meanwhile is drax you
saved my home world from a cree invasion
let us take a picture to send to my wife
and daughter not voiced by dave bautista
though the producers of the show said
that they tried to get in touch with him
but yeah drax is referring to his wife
yvette and their daughter kamaria the
kylosians killed by ronin on thanos's
orders but now another planet saved by
t'challa in this world nebula appears
karen gillan returning to voice her now
unscarred with hardly any cybernetic
implants since thanos must have spent
fewer years torturing her or might not
have tortured her at all t'challa tells
her you know he gardens now you should
talk to me and he really has changed
referring to thanos retirement as a
farmer on the garden in infinity war and
endgame nebula tells him about a heist
she's planning do i have a job for you
they're called the embers of genesis
yeah the music is the same jazzy heist
music used in the ant-man films
i was at a wine tasting with my cousin
ernesto which was mainly red and you
know i don't love reds man you know but
there was a rose that saved the day it
was delightful nebula calls the embers
of genesis nutrient-rich cosmic dust
from an ancient supernova with the power
to terraform entire ecosystems with one
ounce you can heal a dying planet in
minutes yeah the embers of genesis
aren't specifically in the marvel comics
but they do seem like the same kind of
cosmic particles that the eternals might
have used on ancient earth to enrich the
soil for agriculture and yeah this is
the kind of reallocation of resources to
stave off hunger that thanos was
referring to he had nebula butt heads
here i thought you work alone daughter
you mean she's your offspring adopted
yeah i call back to one of my favorite
mc running jokes between thor and loki
and he's my brother he killed 80 people
in two days
he's adopted i've never met this man in
my life he's my brother adopted hey you
know what's just as fun as video games
saving money on video games well thanks
to our friends at ubisoft for sponsoring
this video ubisoft is having sales on
two of their best-selling franchises
assassin's creed valhalla and rainbow
six siege the sale is happening now from
august 12th to august 18th you can save
up to 75 off rainbow six siege choose
your operators and engage on intense
missions in rainbow six siege iconic
maps plus for a limited time play the
containment event and unlock bonus
content then save up to 33 percent off
assassin's creed valhalla play as avor
conquer england and bring glory to your
clan plus save 25 off the assassin's
creed valhalla season pass and try the
newest expansion the siege of paris so
click on the link in the description to
take advantage of these deals going on
now from august 12th to august 18th now
in thanos's absence the collector
tantalia travon seen in guardians of the
galaxy and in infinity war has emerged
instead as the feared tyrant of the
galaxy which does make sense because the
collector for a few minutes in mcu
history had both the power stone in his
possession while the reality stone was
hidden elsewhere in his vault and he
knew what both of those were he was very
close to being a rival of the thanos if
you think about it t'challa and yondu
argue in the eclector this is the
massive ravager ship that yondu escaped
and destroyed in guardians volume 2.
yondu says we steal from the rich and
give to the poor just like that
earthling folk hero of yours right robin
leech robin hood
robin leach marveled over excessive
wealth and lifestyles of the rich and
famous love that joke nebula says the
collector's got a famous kink for exotic
flora and fauna yeah reminding us of
when the collector weirdly offered to
buy groot's corpse now benicio del toro
said in an interview that tyvon sees
himself as a noah figure his collection
an arc to rebuild after some galaxy-wide
destruction and groot as a flora colossi
who respawns after death could be made
of a tissue rooted in the embers of
genesis then on to nowhere devon has the
black order running security so we see
proxima midnight corvus glaive ebony ma
and call obsidian all returning from
infinity war and game but karina greets
them voiced again by ophelia lovabond
from the movies and she introduces them
to tyvon i present to you
tanelia tivan
the collector
oh my dearest nebula aren't you aside
for sore
i forgive me i couldn't help myself
and yes benissa del toro has returned
here to voice a character one of his
collections appears to be a giant
wakandan rhinoceros looking about as
animated as it did in the live-action
film he now wears this elaborate chest
plate that looks as guardian in nature
or at least something designed by e tree
it has these interesting engravings not
too dissimilar from fandral's chest
plate or maybe a version of the
asgardian destroyer in the vault there
is an easy to miss container with the
giant cocoon from the post-credits scene
thor of the dark world which at first
seemed like it was gonna be adam
warlock's cocoon until james gunn
changed it to have a new golden cocoon
in the guardians vol 2 post-credits
scene and then retconned that first one
as an ancient version of the sovereign's
cocoons they pass cosmo the space dog
who growled at rocket in guardians vol 1
but here he wags his tail at t'challa
another contains a dark elf and then of
course howard the duck with seth green
returning as the voice he directs
t'challa to the embers of genesis cosmic
flora down the hall take a louie at the
frost giants to hard ralph at the
cronins you're gonna see a sign for
elvish literature ignore that total
snooze screw it
yeah i love that scared quack at the end
there but yeah he mentioned the frost
giants those are loki's people cronins
those are korg's people and elvish
literature maybe a joke about the long
dramatic elvish dialogue we all had to
sit through in through the dark world
howard says you know what they say when
you're out of luck always go duck i'm
pretty sure no one says that oh they say
it really totally yeah another little
quack at the end there it was a little
rewording of his line in guardians
volume 2. you know what they say you're
out of luck until you've gone done
howard stops for a drink at this bar
that looks a lot like the mos eisley
cantina bar from star wars though the
bartender is the robot that kind of
looked like a celestial that was in the
sakaar bar serving valkyrie drinks and
thor ragnarok so that bar just might be
that setup and t'challa runs into this
garage which is filled with spaceships
that we've seen before front and center
is a commodore that's a pleasure craft
of the grand master endowed gas from
thor ragnarok that's actually tyvon's
brother because they're both elders of
the universe now to the right of that is
another ship from the grand master's
garage that's a green painted cube that
takeaway tt joke that he designed with
an intentionally dumb shape and then to
the right of that closest to us the
quantum realm vessel of hank pym that he
used to rescue janet van dyne now this
being 2008 no it doesn't really make
sense for devon to have this because it
didn't exist yet but above that looks
like an avengers quinjet then further on
on the left is a yellow star blaster
that's a fighter piloted by the nova
corps fleet and to the left of that is a
green ship with folded wings that looks
like another ship from the grandmaster's
garage then to the upper right of the
star blaster is the necrocraft piloted
by ronin sikarian soldiers in guardians
vol 1 and then another one of these was
hijacked by nebula to kamikaze into
thanos on titan infinity war now on the
far left looks like it could be the
milano though the wing engines are
completely different and then just
behind the star blaster looks like it
could be an x-wing from star wars but
the s-foils look completely different
then t'challa's necklace lights up when
he finds a wakandan spacecraft
yeah that was the sound of the talking
drum that was part of composer ludwig
joranson's score for black panther and
again proof that wakandans were involved
in space exploration which is crazy now
the interior of this craft is covered in
wakandan lettering which i took the time
of course to try to translate but i only
made out a few words you understand
wasn't and then you insane then in the
cabin as we face the cockpit it looks
like positive and then on the right side
and negative across the top and then
down the sides simplify and and on the
other side make shapes i don't know what
this is but t'challa finds these
mannequins wearing dora melange garb
meaning the collector must have killed
these soldiers and now has their
wardrobe on display and he sees his
papa's recording
my son
crown prince of wakanda was abducted
from earth by an alien spacecraft if
music there might sound familiar that's
the mournful ancestral plane track from
the black panther score
ebony mob binds t'challa by using the
broken glass similar to how he
repurposed broken material in his fight
against doctor strange and the others in
infinity war siobhan uses a cronin arm
against t'challa packs quite a wallop
does it not i hacked it off the carcass
of a terribly chatty chrome
terribly jetty cronin this guy cut off
korg's arm now during this fight i like
how the talking drum picks up pace just
like it did to build up tension during
t'challa's warrior falls duel in black
panther
javon's weapons include captain
america's shield which in 2008 would
have been frozen in polar ice as well as
mjolnir and then a dagger forged in dark
matter taken from the ruler of the dark
elves that would have been malekith
stagger and then of course the headpiece
of hella whom tyvon emulates with his
gesture oh
that woman has taste a necrosaur
courtesy of the asgardian goddess of
death
no clue how he would have gotten this or
any of this stuff because hella is a
freaking goddess of death i don't see
how he could have taken it from her
meanwhile as thanos and the other fight
in security i love this you can hear a
bowling pin sound effect as he knocks
him over
and when yondu saves t'challa the
guardians of the galaxy music plays
yondu
sweet now it's a party t'challa and
yondu used the sticky fingers trick on
tavon to steal his gauntlet control the
same maneuver tony stark uses on thanos
to steal that gauntlet an end game then
on the reveal we hear this great music
this is more music from the black
panther score
and one of the prisoners closing in on
tavonne is a pluvian the same race as
martin x from stakar oguard's crew from
guardians of galaxy vol 2. as they leave
nowhere the embers of genesis that kill
the black order cause life to spring
from that skull making me wonder if it
could reanimate in some form they return
to wakanda and reunite with the family
queen ramonda is wearing the same white
robes and headpiece that she wore when
she greeted t'challa on his return in
black panther and they all dine okoye in
thanos talk my friend that sounds an
awful lot like genocide no no no because
it's random
then i might add
efficient korath talks with shuri
meanwhile craglin says jump points are
the best they make your face all
scrambly but they're a lot of fun
referring to their light speed jump
sequence in guardians vol 2. and the
final scene takes us to that dairy queen
in missouri this same one from guardians
vol 2. but here adult peter quill
listens to space age love song by a
flock of seagulls could be from james
gunn's awesome mix volume 3 since
volumes 1 and 2 mostly stuck to 70s
music ego says what peter can't spare a
little time for dear old dad and his
ship is parked out front all while the
watcher says too bad this might spell
the end of the world bringing us back to
that nature versus nurture debate of
this episode further prove that nurture
is so so important because for the
watcher to consider this apocalyptic
means that peter needed his experiences
with the ravagers and the guardians he
needed to meet them first in order to
know how wrong his biological connection
to ego was and be able to fight back
against him and the closing title card
pays tribute to the late chadwick
boseman the hero this episode thankfully
gave us another adventure with support
new rockstars by checking out our merch
options at neroxmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you